احنا بنيجي عشان نحتفل بصمه مصريه وهو ده
عيدنا كلنا اللي بنجيله عنوان كبير جدا
جدا لسينما المصريه اهميه الهواء والميه
والحياه بالنسبه لنا كلها
[موسيقى]
المهرجان بيكتسب تاريخه مش بس من
جوده البرنامج همم
وما يقدمه للصناعه المحليه والصناعه لكن
كمان ااا استمراره وعدم انقطاعه ان شاء
الله يفضل دائما ااا مهرجان ناجح ومش
بيعتمد بس على تاريخه بيعتمد على ما يقدمه
كل سنه من جديد للسلام
استضعنا ان احنا نجيب افلام جديده جدا من
جميع انحاء العالم استطعنا ان يبقى عندنا
لجنه تحكيم متميزه جدا درجه اولى استطعنا
ان احنا نجيب مخرج كبير زي فيلا دار هيقول
محاضرات ويعمل ورش كل ده قدرنا ان احنا
نحصل عليه
[موسيقى]
اغنيه على الممر اللي علي عبد الخالق يومي
لتوفيق صالح وانا اخذت قرار ان كل عام
المهرجان نيرمين المصريين من الافلام
الجديده عندنا افلام عظيمه جدا زي السفاره
فوق النيل عندنا فيلم اللص والكلاب عندنا
الحرام عندنا افلام مصريه رائعه ابيض
واسود ويجب ان احنا نحافظ عليها بنحولها
الى الديجيتال عشان نحافظ عليها في
السنوات القادمه ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]